so this thing is actually the logo of
Trinity map Society Trinity College in
Cambridge Mass Society when they have
lectures about mathematics and they go
out socializing to the pub well the
Society has this as their logo is a
square made of other squares but all the
squares of different sizes and so you
see this one here with 50 well that
means it's a 50 unit by 50 unit square
this one here with the 35 is 35 by 35
all these squares are different sizes
yet they fit together to make one big
square which is 112 by 112 so it's
called a squared square why have they
picked this as their logo for their
society their nerves well yeah and that
and because it was Trinity math students
that solved this this one is actually
the smallest possible squared square so
this is something that feels like it
would be done by the ancient Greeks or
something this feels like an old problem
how can you make a square from other
squares of different sizes that feels
like a classic problem list and really
turn up until the 20th century which
surprises me we are integer squares
we're not using the same square twice or
if you do they're called imperfect so
you can use that but I'd rather they're
all different sizes there were four
students and the Trinity map society
that really sold this problem they were
called Arthur stone Cedric Smith Roland
Brooks and built it
the first three were math students built
it was actually a chemistry student but
he was in the math society because we
like math so you don't have to be a
mathematician to be in the math society
and he was arthur stone who brought this
problem in who heard of this problem
before the only thing that had been done
before was there were a couple of
rectangles that have been found made out
of squares not quite the same thing here
they are just two there were just two
rectangles I've been found
one of them uses nine squares the other
uses ten squares rectangles they are
easier than making squares but only two
have been found so far so the students
started to find more their methods were
a little bit add heart
so they were trying to find these
rectangles we were hoping that they
would get lucky and find a square made
out of squares just by chance but it
wasn't working
they kept trying found rectangles but
they couldn't find a square we thought
right we're going to have to get more
systematic so when they started finding
these rectangles made other squares
because okay let's do this
I started to extend the horizontal lines
like this you see this horizontal line
tu-tu-tu-tu-tu-tu right
once you've extended the lines we're
going to turn this rectangle into a
network and what you do is you connect
two horizontal lines if the square are
touching so this one here 25 is touching
these two horizontal lines that's the
top of 25 and that's the bottom of 25 so
I'm just going to connect them with a
line I'm actually going to draw an arrow
here here to show top to bottom and
markets that's the 25 square so I'm just
going to do the whole thing now with the
networks so a 16 that's the top of 16 at
the bottom of 16 so let's connect those
with a line and I'll mark it with 16
after 16 line and then are keep going so
they turned it into a network and when
they did that they recognized it
they went that seems familiar and why
they recognized it was because it
reminded them of an electrical network
if you connect this to a battery and if
these were wires in a network and each
wire has one unit resistance and you
connect it to a battery which has the
same potential as the height of the
rectangle put all these numbers in these
are the currents that flows through that
electrical network so suddenly they
realized that this was connected to
electrical networks and they could use
all this maths that was already there
they could borrow it completely to solve
the squared squared problem in
particular these are called Kirchhoff's
laws a couple of karakov laws are the
current flowing in to our point should
equal the current flowing out of a point
so let's look at the current flowing
into here
thirty-six is flowing in two is flowing
in so we've got thirty eight in total
flowing in and flowing out we've got
thirty three and a five so it they are
equal another thing you can learn from
kerkhof laws if you've got a circuit
like this circuit here a circuit should
make zero I'll show you what I mean
so from going from here we've got a nine
we've got a seven which makes sixteen
and then I go in the opposite direction
here so this is a minus sixteen so
altogether the whole circuit is a zero
yes all this maths suddenly you could
just follow and they could solve the
squared squared problem couple of things
they solved on the way they showed that
the smallest squared rectangle just uses
nine squares and there's two of them
actually that's one of them that's the
smallest squared rectangle meaning it
just uses nine squares and the other one
was that one that was done before then
remember there were two that was done
previously one of those is a small
squared rectangle they showed that there
are no cubed cubes and that's kind of
disappointing you can't make a cube out
of cubes of different sizes so using
these networks they could find what made
valid squared rectangles and what are
not valid grade without having to draw
out the square rectangle so they started
build up a catalog one of the ideas was
if they could find a squared rectangle
and another squared rectangle that had
the same dimensions they could do it
like this a squared rectangle like that
and another one which have the same
dimensions but using completely
different squares inside so they're
mutually exclusive but they're the same
size then you could join them together
like this this would be a square up here
this would be a square here and it would
make a squared squared automatically or
if you can't do that wouldn't have you
so you want to avoid duplicates so you
want two squared rectangles which have
no squares in common that's what they
were looking for or maybe they could
have one square in common if it was a
corner square because you could do this
you can have a rectangle like this
another one that's meant to be exactly
the same dimension that just share one
corner and that would make a squared
square as well so that was their plan
and it worked and they finally found one
the first squared square it was massive
the first one they found it used 55
squares and then he tried to improve it
they wanted to find smaller ones and
they found one that used 38 built it
found one used 26 and these were getting
better and the question was what's the
smallest square square now that is
something they struggled with because it
became too hard a problem and this was a
problem that was then left open for
another 38 years until the 1970s until
computers came along and in using
computers they could use these students
methods that they've done we could use
those methods with a computer and began
searching for squared squares and they
found the smallest uses twenty-one
squares it's definitely the smallest is
unique there's only one squared square
that uses 21 and is it there are non let
use fewer squares and then you can look
at many that uses more than 21 squares
but those students all of them became
mathematicians well one of them became a
civil servant but he was still a Maps
fan I think I was rolling Brooks but the
other three became mathematicians
including Bill Tut who started off as a
chemistry student he swapped over to
maths he then became a Bletchley Park
code breaker
in World War two a very important job
and became a proper mathematician after
the war and he was a pioneer in graph
theory which is the maps of networks and
he credits this problem at his training
in graph theory okay so we've seen this
one which is the smallest squared square
the dimensions of it is 112 units 512
units there is actually smaller squares
which talk about dimensions that we use
more squares and they're not unique
either there are three known squares
that are that site there are smaller
dimensions that the
more squares one thing I found that was
interesting theoretically we can do this
one squared plus two squared plus three
squared plus 4 squared
imagine consecutive squares going up to
24 squared is equal to a big number I'm
not even sure what it is where I can
tell you what it is it's 70 squared
which means that it is theoretically
possible to make a square which is 70 by
70 made out of consecutive squares 1 2 3
4 a bit that you can't be done it's so
tempting the maths looks like it can be
done but geometrically we don't fit
together ice so disappointing I know B
like a magic squared square perfect
super perfect and it's so disappointing
it doesn't exist
ah well it does it no doesn't another
favorite square square well is this one
I say Steve it because this one was
actually found before the Trinity
students found theirs they were scooped
everyone else is like a very nice square
is it don't when should we tell Matt he
seems so excited about it you know what
I am excited about it this is